The first principle of knowledge based AI, as we have discussed it in CS7637,
is that AI agents use heuristics to find solutions that are good enough, but
not necessarily optimal. Some schools of AI put a lot of emphasis on
finding the optimal solution to every problem. In knowledge based AI,
we consider agents that find solutions that are good enough.
Herbert Simon called this satisficing. The reason for
finding solutions that are only good enough is because of the trade off between
computational efficiency on one hand and optimality of solutions on the other.
We can find optimal solutions, but that comes with the cost of
computational efficiency. Recall one of the conundrums of AI. AI agents
are with limited resources, bounded rationality, limited processing power,
limited memory size. Yet, most intrusting problems are impractical. How can
we get AI agents to solve impractical problems with limited rationality and yet
give nearly a ten performance? We can get AI agents to do that if we can
focus on finding solutions that are good enough, but not necessarily optimum.
Most of the time you and I as human agents do not find optimum solutions.
The plan you may have to make dinner for
yourself tonight is not necessarily optimum, it's just good enough.
The plan that you have to go from your house to your office is not
necessary optimal, it's just good enough. The plan that you have to walk from
your car to your office is not necessary optimal, it's just good enough.
Further, AI agents use heuristics to find solutions that are good enough.
They do not do an exhaustive search, even the exhaustive search might yield
more optimal solutions because exhaustive search is computationally costly.
We came across this notion of heuristic search several times in this course.
Once place where we discussed this in some detail, was in incremental concept
learning. Given a current concept definition and a negative example, we arrive
at a new concept definition by using heuristics like require-link heuristic.
The require-link heuristic adds the must clause to this support link
between these two bricks. Mean-sense analysis was a heuristic method. It said
that given the current position and the goal position, find the differences and
then select an operator that will reduce the difference. Because mean-sense
analysis was a heuristic method sometimes it ran into problems and
did not follow guarantees of optimality. But when it worked,
it was very efficient. Another case where we explicitly made use of heuristic
laws in the generate interest method. Here we had a heuristic which said,
do not generate a state that duplicates a previously generated state
which made the method more efficient. Does the focus of knowledge based
AI agents is a near real time performance? They're addressing computational
intractable problems with bounded resources. And yet being able to solve a very
large class of problems in robust intelligence and flexible intelligence. And
that happens not by finding optimal solutions to a narrow class of problems, but
by using heuristics to find solutions that are good enough to very large classes
of problems. This principle comes very much from theories of human cognition.
As I mentioned earlier, humans do not normally find optimal solutions for
every problem they face. However, we do manage to find solutions that
are good enough, and we do so in near real time, and that's where the power lies